okay so I have a definition of
narcissism that's a little different
from other people's
normally we think of a narcissist as
someone who loves themself and I'm
actually saying that a narcissist is a
person who doesn't love them sub
sufficiently so in order to get through
life we have to have a degree of self
esteem we have to think that we're
worthy of certain things we have to have
a sense of inner worth if we don't have
that kind of bedrock from within we
constantly need attention and validation
from other people right I need attention
I need to stir trouble I need to feed my
ego I can't get it from myself I have to
get it from other people mm-hmm that's a
classic what I call it deep narcissist
and that's why they cause so many
problems in life and I measure it I say
that imagine it like a water line and
here at the top is someone who's not a
narcissist here at the middle is kind of
an average person and as you sink deeper
into narcissism you're more and more
self-absorbed you can never get up to
that mid-level point where you can start
thinking about other people at the high
point you're someone who's very
empathetic you're able to get inside the
mind of other people you understand
their moods their emotions most of us
fall at that range of maybe 60% 50 being
the middle line we have moments of
narcissism where we get self-absorbed
particularly we have problems and we we
turn inward but then we have enough
self-esteem because of our parents
because of our background that we raise
ourselves back up and we don't keep
continually sinking into that narcissism
we want to get higher we want to get to
that level where we're able to be more
empathetic a deep narcissist has sunk so
far below that they can never get up to
even to that halfway point there's so
self-absorbed they're so insecure they
constantly must stir up trouble they
need to be the center of attention if to
be the center of attention means to
create a great work of art that's fine
but sometimes to be the center of
attention means to mess with people to
create problems to stir up trouble and
to be that at the center of that once
somebody is at that level like a 20 or
30 I'm these are just arbitrary now sure
there's nothing that's going to raise
them back up
who they are there's nothing they can do
there's almost nothing other people can
do they are they are what's the word
their damaged goods a lot of nothing
that can happen I don't think so
Wow and so those are some strong words
right there well I have a story actually
a story that got cut from the book if
you got my bonus material if you
preorder the laws of human nature you
get some bonus material there's a story
I cut that I gave you about Robert
Oppenheimer the physicist who was a deep
narcissist who managed to kind of cure
himself and the way he cured himself was
through work instead of absorbing
himself in getting attention he put all
of his energy into the Manhattan Project
and into later becoming a great
physicist sort of a public figure he
turned against nuclear arms etc he sort
of cured himself you can perhaps cure
yourself through your work through
getting out of this person getting your
attention through what you achieve
rather than through what you stir up
from other people but generally once you
get down past that the low level there's
nothing you can do because you're
addicted to that you're addicted to
getting attention from other people